hey guys so in the last video i was
talking about how you can define a
function whose graph is a plane and
moreover a plane that passes through a
specified point and whose orientation
you can somehow specify and we ended up
seeing how specifying that orientation
comes down to certain partial derivative
information and first let me just kind
of repeat what the conclusion was but
i'll put it in more abstract terms since
i did it in a very specific example last
time so basically if you want some kind
of function
which gives you a plane that passes
through a certain point well first let's
see what that point is right let's say
the point was
x naught y naught and z naught so these
are just constant values and this is my
way of abstractly describing a single
point in space using
x naught to represent a constant x value
y not to represent constant y value that
kind of thing so what it is is it's
going to be some sort of other constant
a multiplied by x minus
x naught
so this this white x here is the
is the variable and then x naught is
just a constant uh let me let me go
ahead and
let me go ahead and pick that
parenthesis there okay so then we add to
that
b
multiplied by and then b is just some
other constant just like a is some other
constant multiplied by y minus
y naught
and then all of that you add
z naught
and now if you were just presented this
as it is it's kind of a lot right
there's five different constants going
on but really what this is saying is you
want something where
the partial derivative with respect to x
is just some constant and you want to be
able to specify what that constant is
and similarly the partial derivative
with respect to y is another constant
and you just want to ensure that this
passes through this point x naught y
naught z naught and if you imagine
plugging in x the variable equals x
naught the constant this part goes to
zero similarly plugging in y naught the
constant makes this part go to zero so
this is a way of specifying that when
you evaluate the function at x not y
naught it equals z naught
and that's what makes sure that the
graph passes through that point
so with that said
let's start thinking about how you can
find the tangent plane to a graph and
first of all let's think about what that
what that point is how you specify such
a point instead of specifying any three
numbers in space because you have to
make sure the point is somewhere on the
graph you instead only specify two
you're basically going to say what's the
x coordinate and in this case let's say
the x coordinate was like one that'd be
like 1 and then the y coordinate which
looks about like negative 2. and to make
it easier i'm just going to say let's
say it is negative 2. then the z
coordinate is specified because this is
a graph the z coordinate is forced to be
whatever the output of the function is
at one negative two so this is going to
be whatever the output of our function
is
at one
negative two
and f here f is going to be whatever
function gives us this graph so maybe i
should maybe i should write down the
actual function that i'm using for this
graph in this case
f which is a function of x and y
is equal to
minus
1 3 of x squared
minus y squared
okay so this is the function that we're
using and you evaluate it at that point
and this will give you your your point
in three dimensional space that our
linear function that our tangent plane
has to pass through so we can start
writing out our function right we can
say okay so our linear function as a
function of x and y
it's got to make sure it goes through
that 1 and that negative 2. so this is
going to be some constant a that we'll
fill in in a moment multiplied by x
minus that one
plus and then b also a constant that
we'll specify in a moment times y minus
that negative 2 so it's minus
and negative 2
and then the whole the the thing that we
add to it is f of 1 negative 2. and
let's just go ahead and evaluate that
let's say we plug in 1 and negative 2.
so if we go up here and we plug in so
that would be 3 minus x equals 1
3 minus
1 3 of
if x equals 1 1 3 of 1 squared so that's
1 3 1 squared minus and then y is
negative two
so that will be minus negative two
squared
so that's three
minus a third
minus
four
so the whole thing is equal to let's see
three minus four is negative one minus
another third is negative
four thirds okay so that's what we add
to this entire thing we add
negative
four
thirds and maybe i should just kind of
make clear
the separation here so this is our
function
but we don't know what a and b are those
are things that we need to plug in
now the whole idea of a tangent plane is
that the partial derivative with respect
to x should match that of the original
function
so if we go over to the graph here and
start thinking about partial derivative
information if we want the partial
derivative with respect to x and you
imagine moving purely in the x direction
here
um this intersects the graph along some
kind of curve and what the partial
derivative with respect to x at this
point tells you is the slope of the
tangent line well i'm kind of bad at
drawing there this
is the slope of the tangent line uh in
that direction of that point so that's
what the partial derivative with respect
to x is telling you and what you want
when you look at the tangent of the
tangent plane
is that the tangent plane also has that
same slope you know you kind of if i
line things up here you'd want it also
to have that same slope so you can
specify over here and say a
we want a
to be equal to the partial derivative of
the function
with respect to x
evaluated at this 1 negative 2 evaluated
at that special point 1
negative 2. and then similarly
b
for pretty much the same reasons and
i'll draw it out here so let's kind of
ah
let's erase this line
so instead of intersecting it with that
slice
let's see what movement in the y
direction looks like so in this case it
looks like a very steep slope right
because in this case the tangent line in
that direction is a pretty steep slope
and now when we bring in
when we bring in the tangent plane uh it
should intersect with that constant
constant x value plane along that same
slope
made it kind of messy there but you can
you can see the the
the line formed by intersecting these
two planes should be that desired
tangent and what that corresponds to in
formulas is that this b which represents
the partial derivative of l
um l is the the tangent plane function
that should be the same
as if we take the partial derivative of
f
with respect to y
at that point at this point 1 negative
2.
and this is stuff that we can compute
and that we can figure out so let's just
kind of start plugging that in first let
me just copy this function because we're
going to need it
copy
and now let's go on down here
i'm just going to
let's paste it down here kind of in the
bottom because that's what we'll need so
let's compute the partial derivative of
f with respect to x so we look down here
the only place where x shows up is in
this negative one third of x squared
context so the the partial derivative of
f with respect to x
is going to be just the derivative of
this little guy which is negative we
bring down the two negative two thirds
of x
so when we go ahead and plug in you know
x equals one to see what what it looks
like when we evaluate at this point
that's just going to be equal to
negative two-thirds so that tells us
that a is going to have to be negative
two-thirds now for similar reasons let's
let's go ahead and compute the
the partial derivative with respect to y
we look down here well the only place
that y shows up in the entire expression
is this negative y squared so
the partial derivative of f
with respect to y
is equal to just negative 2 y
negative 2 y and now when we plug in y
equals negative 2
what we get is negative 2 multiplied
coincidentally by negative 2 that didn't
have to be the case that those were the
same
and that whole thing equals 4.
so the partial derivative of f with
respect to y evaluated at this point 1
negative 2 is equal to 4. so if we were
to plug this information back up into
our formula we would replace a with
negative 2 thirds we would say negative
2 thirds and we would replace b with
four
replace b
with four and that would give us the
full formula
the full formula um for the tangent
plane and this could be kind of a lot to
look at at first because we have to
specify the input point you know 1
negative 2 and then we had to figure out
where the function evaluates at that
point and then we had to figure out both
of the partial derivatives with respect
to x and with respect to y but all in
all there's not actually a lot to
remember for how you go about computing
this looking at the graph actually makes
things seem a lot more reasonable
because each of those terms has an
actual meaning if we look at the
1 and negative 2 that's just telling us
the input the kind of x and y
coordinates of the input and of course
we have to evaluate that because
that tells us the z coordinate that'll
put us on the graph
corresponding to that point and then to
get us a tangent plane you just need to
specify the two bits of partial
differential information and that'll
tell you kind of how this graph needs to
be oriented and once you start thinking
things in that way you know
geometrically even though there's a lot
going on here there's five different
numbers you have to put in um each one
of them feels like yeah yeah of course
you need that number otherwise you
couldn't specify a tangent plane there's
kind of a lot of information required to
put it on the appropriate spot
so with that i will see you next video